افاده مراسل الجزيره في باكستان بان
مؤيدين لحزب انصاف فاغلقوا الطريقه
السريعه الرابط بين العاصمه اسلام اباد
واقليم البنجر
وخيبر وعبر وزير الداخليه عن خشيته من
وقوع الصدامات بين المتضررين من الاغلاق
وانصار حزب انصاف كما ندد بموقف الحكومه
المحليتين في البنجاب وخيبر داعيا والشرطه
المحليه في الاقليمين بعدم السماحي
باستمرار اغلاق الطريق السريع وتمكنه
السلطات من اقناع المحتاجين بفتح الطريق
بين العاصمه ومطاري اسلام اباد الذي يقع
عمليا خارج العاصمه ويتسبب الاغلاق في
تراب حركه المركبات والشاحنات والتيبات
يتعين عليها اللجوء لطرقنا الالتفافيه
بديله
بعد ينضم الينا مدير مكتبنا عبد الرحمن
مطر عبد الرحمن ما طبيعه المشهد الان مع
محاولات فتح الطرقات
طبعا
الاغلاق ما زال مستمر مؤيدوه حزب انصاف
زعامه عمران خان ما زالوا يغلقون الطريق
السريع الرابط بين العاصمه اسلام بدر
واقليم خيبر وايضا بين العاصمه بعد وطريق
واقليم البنجاب هناك حاليا همم طريق سريع
مغلق من الجهتين يعني من يريد المغادره
مغادر الى اقليم البنجاب لا يستطيع وكذلك
من يريد المغادره الى اقليم خيبر الا عبر
طرق التفافيه وترابيه وحقيقه يعني متعبه
للغايه وتحديدا بالنسبه للسائقي الشاحنات
الكبيره التي يصعب عليها بالتاكيد المرور
في الطرق الصغيره اضافه بالتاكيد للحافلات
الكبيره المخصصه للنقل المسافرين هذا
الوضع انه محاوله الى حد ما وين كانت
رمزيه من جانب حزب الانصاف لمحاصره
العاصمه اسلام اباد واغلاقها بطريقه اخرى
هو ربما اثار وزير الداخليه اليوم الذي ما
تزال وزارته تسعه لمحاوله الحصول على ما
يسمى بالتفويض الحكومي لممارسه صلاحيات
اوسع خارج العاصمه سنبات كي تتمكن قوى
الامن من فتح الطريق
واجبارهاؤلاء المغلقين من حزب انصاف على
التخلي عن اغلاقهم للطريق هناك على ما
يبدو تحدي من جانب حزب انصاف الذي يسيطر
بالمناسبه على الحكمتين الاقليمتين في
البنجاب وفي خيبر تحدي للحكومه المركزيه
هنا في اسلام اباد وبالتاكيد كل هذا هو في
من تداعيات محاوله اغتيال زعيم حزب انصاف
عمران خان وما بعد ذلك من اتهامه لوزير
الداخليه ورئيس الحكومه وضربه المخابرات
بالوقوف وراء محاوله اغتيال والتخطيط لها
وايضا نافع الحكومه طلوعها في محاوله
اغتيال المشهد حقيقه يعني معقد سياسيا
وقضائيا وحاليا على المستوى الامني حاليا
حتى المواطن البسيط المسافر بين اسلام
اباد وغيرها من الاقليم يعاني حقيقه بسبب
ذلك الخلافه السياسي المتفاق من هنا في
باكستان شكرا لك مدير مكتبنا عبد الرحمن
مطار من اسلام اباد